l'europe était à feu et à sang
on allait tous et laisser sa peau il y
avait débarqué et avancer sur paris
les allemands voulaient tout détruire
tout raser spécialement paris
l'explosion des bombes a provoqué une
crue spectaculaire de la scène continué
mentionnant bas cinq minutes après les
ponts la cathédrale notre dame le paiera
rien ne résistera volonté du führer
pourquoi tenez vous tant détour cette
ville monsieur le gouverneur faire
détrompez-vous si on ne m'avait pas
demandé d'entrer en contact avec vous ce
matin je dormirai encore sans douté de
rien comme tous ces gens vous apprêtez à
tuer un peu de temps je pouvais arrêter
de parler de gesticuler sans arrêt ce
sont des civils des civils pour qui
cette gare est une aberration et qu'ils
n'ont jamais commis le moindre forfait
contre vous parmi toutes celles qui vont
périr combien yat-il d'enfants qui ont
l'âge des vôtres vous y réfléchirez 0 je
te nouméa pareil pour rétablir l'ordre
j'ai l'intention de faire bien davantage
et que comptez-vous faire exactement je
les écraserait tous vous m'entendez tous
tu t'es trompé sur vos général sur moi
s'est cru qu'en venant ici je pourrai
vous dissuader de faire une chose aussi
formé
ah si l'on devait en plus de ce dôme
mais en plus low prenait la place de la
concorde
et en plus ces enfants jouer dans les
parcs
il est deux tours de notre-dame
toutefois est ce pareil pour toujours
et vous n'avez aucun remords
mais quelle heure mais tout autant